Okay. So we are going to build a Web site--
right now--called ASCII Chan.
And this is going to be a message board
for sharing ASCII Art.
It's going to have this general structure
where we will have a form with--
you know--it'll take a title and some ASCII Art--
a little submit button--
and the user can submit this and below this form,
they'll see ASCII Art that's been submitted by other people--things like that.
So it'll be a one-page Web site.
It'll have a form, and then the contents here.
So for those of you who don't know what ASCII Art is,
let me give you a few examples.
Here we are, on this Web site, Chris.com--
pretty awesome domain name.
This Web site is dedicated to ASCII Art,
and as you can see here--
I'm just looking at a bunch of ASCII Art of cows.
All ASCII Art is--it's just little pictures, drawn with keyboard characters.
SO pretty cool; there's this huge--huge--encyclopedia of ASCII Art online
and we are going to build a forum
for people to share their own ASCII Art.
Anyway, if you haven't seen it before, that's what it is.
It's a fantastic way for people to
waste time in front of their keyboards.
Okay. Here we go.